this
is with us liz is in los angeles hi liz
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call i have a
quick question
um i currently have an rv
and which i live in um and my car will
be paid
off in about a month i owe 17 000 on
that
so i will have it paid off next month um
and i wanted to get your opinion because
i want to just i
full time in my rv and i don't want to
buy a house
so i wanted to get your opinion as far
as
what would be the income for when i do
retire
what amount should i be saving currently
i'm doing seven hundred dollars a month
in my roth and 400 in my 401k
good for you well you're saving a lot of
money you're how old
yeah and i have um 46 and i have um
20 to 25 000 in my savings
okay well well done very well done is
the rv paid for
no that's the thing i do owe on the rv
um after i was paying my car i owe 45.
okay and so your plan is for the next 45
years to live in an rv
well my grandmother's giving me property
she has given me property
um i'm not sure it's all paid for she
owns a couple of houses
but i'm like oh god what are the taxes
going to be on that so i'm not sure
what's the property okay so you oh how
much on the rv again
45 000. okay and is it worth that
oh yeah it's brand new it's brand new
you put a large down payment what's it
worth what'd you pay for it
um i paid 65 and had it paid off
in three years okay well i can answer i
mean there's
there's several lenses through which you
would look at this situation lens number
one is what do you want to do with your
life how do you want to live your life
you obviously like being in a situation
where you can roll
right and you're that's a lifestyle
decision i've got friends that retired
bought rvs and are rving right
and they sold their house and uh so i
i mean that that's a lifestyle decision
and you get to decide that i'm not i
don't speak into that and it sounds kind
of cool actually but
uh financially it's a horrible game plan
long term
because 40 years from now 30 years from
now this rv is worth
zero versus owning a home would have
gone up dramatically in value during
that same period of time
with the exact same price
so you know if you're asking me
financially is a good
can you absorb the blow yeah i mean
you've got this
land coming to you and some other stuff
you'll be fine
but if i said you know what is a
strategy for building wealth and
creating a stable
financial platform to live my life and
retire with
it's not going to be an rv the rv is
going to be a
uh a toy on the side of this
program not a method of handling my
housing
that is financially efficient because
it's going down in value
you're turning a hundred thousand
dollars into zero instead of a hundred
thousand dollars into five hundred
thousand
does that make sense yeah it does
so it's not a rush it's not a panic it's
not to say oh you're stupid and you need
to sell it today
i'm not saying you need to sell it today
you need to run off and buy a house i'm
not saying that at all
i am saying that for a 40-year game plan
it doesn't work
so you need to accentuate your game plan
you need to add to your game plan
the ownership of a piece of real estate
that you pay cash for eventually or pay
off eventually
um and that could be five years from now
i'm okay with that
uh but but is this a 40-year game plan
answer
no it's not a good 40-year game plan um
even with lifestyle and uh
so forth so